there's another cultural debate raging
across the english channel where a
french left-wing politician is under
fire for saying white people should
stay out of discussions on racism
critics say the remarks are yet another
sign of how u.s style
woke culture is undermining french
values
auntie charlotte dubinsky has more the
anti-white debate has been stirred up
once again here in france this time
after a black politician waded into a
row that's been raging over student
union
which admitted it held meetings about
discrimination that excluded
white people it exists
it exists this reunions exist
now audrey pulvar who's a member of the
paris local authority and is standing in
the upcoming regional elections
has added her to sense she suggested
white people
could be allowed into those meetings but
only
if they keep quiet
i'm not saying anyone should be banned
from entering but they should stay
silent and let others speak on issues
that concern them
her comments have severed opinion
as france grapples to deal with a rise
in identity politics
for those on the right this is seen as
an unwelcome american
import that's undermining universalist
french values a form of cancer culture
in my region no resident should be
discriminated against for the color of
their skin
there is no such thing as acceptable
racism
i will always be a bulwark against those
who try to fracture our country
others went even further saying that
audrey pulvar
and the unef students union were the
stuff of
martin luther king's nightmares
martin luther king would be turning in
his grave he who dreamed of living in a
country where people would not be
judged by the colour of their skin but
by the qualities of their personality
but audrey pulvar's remarks gain support
from
some on the left including from the
leader of france and bowed
who said that she had merely understood
what a discussion group
is politicians have been more than vocal
but what do ordinary people think is it
okay to exclude
white people from a debate and if so is
that
racist it's an absolute horror
i don't know how people can legitimize
such nonsense
we should dismantle these racist remarks
from scratch
for me it's not acceptable to exclude
white people from meetings
i view that as racist
i think it's perfectly legitimate to
exclude white people from the meetings
france has always been a country which
respects human rights and does not look
primarily at the colour of people's skin
i'm not personally concerned about
anti-white racism
but i think it exists
if it were the other way around if the
national party or a right-wing mp
said that black or arabic people should
be quiet during an event
dedicated to the victims of terrorism
that would also cause
public outrage the entire political
class or the media would justifiably
rail against this person and condemn him
because it's racist
france only sees three colours blue
white and red
it distinguishes between citizens only
on their merits and not on their roots
race or religion
i think this is very serious obviously
the statement by audrey polwa is racist
and should be universally condemned
there can be no double standards here
racism is universal
unfortunately there are various forms of
racism and hatred and we are faced with
this
everywhere
you